SPEAKER: This section gives
you an introduction to Cloud.
Cloud computing enables you to
consume server infrastructure
and software platforms as a
service over the internet.
You don't have to
buy and maintain
expensive hardware
in your data center.
Infrastructure
includes raw resources
such as virtual machines,
networking, storage, and more.
These resources are the
fundamental building blocks
of cloud computing.
When you consume infrastructure
as a service, IaaS,
you have greater control
over the resources, but also
greater management overhead.
For example, consider
a virtual machine.
You need to install,
upgrade, and patch
all the software required
to run your application.
You could configure
your virtual machines
to scale based on the
load on your application.
Google Compute Engine,
networking, and load balancers
are examples of IaaS.
Platform as a service,
PaaS, provides a platform
with managed services where
runtime environment and network
settings are pre-configured.
This makes it easier for
you to develop and deploy
your application.
Google App Engine is an example
of platform as a service.
Google App Engine comes
pre-configured with runtimes
for Java, Python,
Node, and more.
Software upgrades and patches
are automatically applied.
Load balancing is
also reconfigured.
This enables the developer to
focus on the application logic
only instead of worrying
about infrastructure setup.
With software as
a service, SaaS,
entire applications
are managed and made
available in the
cloud environment
Gmail as an example of
a software as a service.
This slide shows how
you can use Google Cloud
Platform for application
data, application
logic, and integration
with other Google services.
Imagine an online shopping
website or a mobile app.
The application needs
to store and retrieve
different types of
data as follows.
The website or app
displays images of items
such as shoes and clothes.
These images can be stored
in Google Cloud Storage.
High volume, semi-structured
data like gaming or streaming
data can be stored in NoSQL
databases such as Cloud
Datastore and Bigtable.
Customer information
can be stored
in a relational database, such
as Cloud SQL or Cloud Spanner.
Application logic can
be deployed and executed
on Google App Engine or
Google Kubernetes engine.
You can integrate with other
Google services, such as Google
Maps and YouTube.
All of this infrastructure
can be started up
in just a few minutes without
buying hardware or installing
software.